[Music]
the time for talk is over
now the biggest countries on earth are
fighting for global supremacy
what would happen if the united states
started world war iii
who would the u.s attack first
could we use robot soldiers
or would nuclear power win the day
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the united states started
world war iii
imagine that for decades the tension
between the united states russia and
china has been rising
whether it's through spies or tariffs
these nations constantly battle to
one-up each other and control the
resources on our planet
but if you want to see what it takes to
play a game of global stakes you need to
download conflict of nations this free
online game puts you in competition with
up to
128 other players as you fight epic
battles to take over this virtual world
build alliances declare war and defend
your country against tanks jets and even
nuclear arms
conflict of nations allows you to take
control of a country and manage
resources terrain and even your
population and highly logistical
gameplay that could last weeks
this modern warfare simulator redefines
strategy and combat games and you can
play it anywhere on your pc or mobile
device
click on the link in the description
below and get one month of premium
subscription free along with 13 000 gold
with only 30 days to act this deal won't
last long so get your exclusive gift now
and choose your strategy it's time to
fight your way to victory
while wars of the past started over
border disputes and assassinations
world war iii could start in a virtual
space
and if another cyber attack from china
triggers the united states to respond
the conflict could grow into the most
devastating war ever known
but if a war started tomorrow
would technology dominate over humans
world war ii claimed about 75 million
lives from 1939 to 1945.
it left japan and europe in shambles and
scarred a generation but if the united
states starts world war three
the death toll could be much higher and
happen faster
and with the trade war between the
united states and china escalating
the western superpower could attack one
of its biggest rivals
so
what weapons would it use to strike
first
drone technology has changed the face of
modern warfare during the past few years
and now you may not even see it coming
the military could outfit drones with
adaptive camouflage
small electronic panels that can display
different patterns
these lightweight aircraft could slip
right by you and you wouldn't know until
it's too late
but what if these drones attacked you
weapons manufacturers are developing a
compact laser capable of shooting down
missiles aircraft and drones
while your naked eye could miss these
high-flying threats
the laser's powerful beam could track
and tear through these drones
and on the ground
soldiers could have the same kind of
precision weapons
self-steering bullets could change how
troops eliminate moving targets when
fighting face to face
while the u.s government hasn't
disclosed the details of how this
technology works
these bullets have frightening accuracy
even in windy conditions
but as 2020 taught us
populations can be decimated without a
bullet ever being fired
the centers for disease control listed
30 microorganisms and toxins that
terrorists could weaponize against a
population
with the right delivery systems these
warring nations could use pathogens like
the hantavirus or anthrax against each
other
while bio weapons are nothing new most
agents lose 50 percent of their
effectiveness in the air due to heat and
humidity
but if nations want to cause mass
destruction
they would unleash the worst weapon they
have available
although china has over 100 missile
silos
the government has said they wouldn't
strike first
but if this war became desperate enough
that could change
the united states owns over 5600 nuclear
missiles and its political rival russia
has over 6 000 warheads ready to strike
but the idea of mutually assured
destruction has prevented all sides from
using this apocalyptic threat
but if cyber attacks took down air
defenses and missile controls
all bets might be off
one warhead exploded over new york could
instantly take out 300 000 people
moscow and its surrounding areas could
suffer almost 200 000 deaths in the
blink of an eye
and that's only if two warheads were
launched one over each city
city after city across the globe could
be wiped out in this war to end all wars
war iii could end all life on earth if
these nations didn't work out their
differences
but what if we tried using these nukes
to save the world
what if we nuked an asteroid on course
to hit earth
uh that asteroid is getting closer so it
looks like you'd better claim that offer
from conflict of nations while you're
here click on the link below and get
your one month free premium subscription
and 13 000 gold
and we'll see you on the next what if